and with that I'm gonna take a deep
breath and let's bring in our panel
Steve Hays editor-in-chief of the Weekly
Standard Karen Tumulty opinion writer
for The Washington Post and Charles hurt
opinion editor for The Washington Times
so Steve does it happen I think there
will eventually be some kind of a summit
I don't know if it'll be a Trump Kim
face-to-face some it I don't think it's
likely to happen in the in the coming
months I think it was smart for the
president to take a step back here he
seemed at least in his public comments
very eager for not only the summit
before a deal saying things about Kim
jong-eun that I don't think we're true
giving him too much respect saying he
was very open and very honorable at one
point the president tweeted that Kim
jong-un had agreed to denuclearization
which he hadn't so I think it's smart
that the president took a step back here
I think he had Mike Pompeo and John
Bolton in his ear on either side of him
telling him reminding him of the history
of the North Korean behavior on this and
the history really matters I mean it's
not it's not as if Kim Jong moon is
actually going to give up his nuclear
weapons program
it's been a key component of the regime
for three decades it will remain a key
component of the regime and anything has
to start with that premise I think
speaking of presidential tweets we have
one here let's take a look the president
tweeting very good news to receive the
warm and productive statement from North
Korea we will soon see where it leads
hopefully to long and enduring
prosperity and peace only time and
talent will tell and Sarah Sanders the
press secretary also provided this
update as the president said this
morning certainly we'd like to have a
meeting but the president's not just
looking to have a meeting he's not
looking for just a cheap political stunt
he wants to get something that's a long
lasting and actual real solutions so
Karen your thoughts at this stage well
of course we should all be rooting for a
long-lasting and real solution but it's
not only time and talent I would hope
that the administration one of the
things that they have learned is that
the other two things that you need going
into this kind of meeting are
preparation and message discipline and
both of those things really seem to be
lacking starting from the moment that
President Trump announced that this
summit was happening without consulting
his foreign policy advisors or you know
his own administration Charlie your
thoughts at this stage well you know I
think it's interesting you know they
listened to some of the Democrats
complain about nitpick with some of the
strategy here I think it's a politically
tone-deaf because as you say Karen
everybody should be rooting for some
success here and and the notion that you
have some Democrats obviously just
making a partisan claim criticizing the
president for even having the meetings
and giving him some static Ames
jung-hoon some new stature that he
should have had oh my goodness we just
went through eight years of not only
whatever they called it the strategic
and difference in Korea but also the
negotiations with Iran the problem
wasn't that they were negotiating with
Iran it's that they fell for a terrible
deal and of course John Kerry during
that time was so desperate to get a deal
he practically moved in with the foreign
minister of Iran and wound up with a
really really bad deal and so that's the
problem there and so I think that sit
back now and have Democrats almost
gleeful when the the when the calls you
know the talks got called off it's just
it's a it's they're tone-deaf again
politically speaking with some of this
the art of the deal at work essentially
you saw the president pull out yesterday
and the North Koreans last night around
news timers saying oh wait a minute we'd
still like to talk I think the president
at least deserves some Running Room here
for for it being exactly that and to
have you know somebody like Bob Menendez
lecturing Mike Pompeo yesterday but you
know the art of the deal is not the same
as art of diplomacy well my goodness I
mean the experts have been in charge for
a long time and what do we have we have
a nuclear North Korea and nearly a
nuclear Iran so obviously maybe
switching it up and trying something
different might not be a bad idea
Karen do you think we'll be back and
forth and back and forth on whether this
is going to happen in the coming weeks
yes I do I mean that however you know
one thing we have also learned I think
from this is that you know when
President Trump was running for office
he said I like to be unpredictable he
has I think discovered that that
you know you can overdo unpredictability
as well Steve we've seen a bit of a
dynamic of Mike Pompeo perhaps being the
good cop in these negotiations and then
John Bolton behind the scenes perhaps
being the bad cop is that your read of
things well if you've got Mike Pompeo
being the good cop on North Korea that's
a pretty hawkish place to be I would
imagine that Mike Pompeo is giving the
president advice that suggests he takes
seriously this long history that we
talked about earlier and not fall for
any public gestures that Kim jong-un
might engage in Pompeo knows arguably
more about this than anybody else he's
been there he's met with him I think he
probably has a good sense of what the
actual ask was what the real
conversations were better than anybody
else but he's also I think quite aware
of this history and the history is what
I think has to be our guide as we go
into these discussions so how do you see
the next few weeks I mean I think
Karen's right I expect it'll be
unpredictable I expect there will be
more ad hoc decision-making you know it
can be a strategic advantage to be
unpredictable with your with your
enemies but if you're working with your
allies it's not a good thing to have our
South Korean allies be totally shocked
and sort of spun up into bewilderment by
an announcement like this it's important
to keep them on board to talk to the
Japanese talk to talk to others that
need to be supporting what we're doing
in these talks in the end does the Dear
Leader walk away from the table well the
thing is that one thing we have to
understand is what these nuclear weapons
mean to kim jeong-hoon and they are
literally tied to his actual physical
survival so I think that again we have
to understand this is not you know the
president keeps saying well we could
bring you economic prosperity and we
could guarantee your safety
Kim jong-un knows he's got a guarantee
of his personal safety and those are
those nuclear weapons charlie briefly do
you expect a result yeah I do think that
they will it may not be on the date that
they predicted but I do predict that
there will be some kind of meeting